I think the unemployment topic in
particular when it comes to the young
generations one of the most serious
topics we see this not only in the world
but also in Turkey when I look into
Turkey roughly 400,000 graduates every
year and a huge percentage of them are
unemployed and I think what we in
particular have to do is focus to bring
and give this young generation
opportunity now I think the technology
overall that we are having it gives us a
young generation a chance actually to
start their career early enough and for
this we have to in particular I believe
strongly to use the social media
environment that gives us young
generation a chance but investing for
them is of course also to being very
much proactive and I think that is
actually the future education proactive
using new technology to resolving the
Global's